words are like keys
if you choose them right they can open
any heart and shut any mouth
when you build in silence
people don't know what to attack
if you tell the truth you don't have to
remember anything
be selfish with your time
a lot of people don't deserve it
silence is the best answer to someone
who doesn't value your words
turn your wounds into wisdom
if you only walk on sunny days
you'll never reach your destination
people inspire you
or they drain you
pick them wisely
fear is temporary
regret is forever
your future needs you
your past doesn't
one day the people that don't even
believe in you will tell everyone how
they meant you
don't cry because it's over
smile because it happened
allow yourself to be a beginner
no one starts off being excellent
the quieter you become
the more you can hear
do it alone
do it broke
do it tired
do it scared
just do it
don't get burned twice by the same Flame
life isn't about waiting for the storm
to pass
it's about learning to dance in the rain
worrying about losing is losing before
you begin
excuses make today easier but tomorrow
harder
discipline makes today hard
but tomorrow easier
as long as you are alive
no obstacle is permanent
your struggle is part of your story
you only fail when you stop trying
don't give up
you are closer than you think
be teachable
you're not always right
sometimes being alone is the best
medicine to your soul
we fall we break
we fail
but then we rise we heal
we overcome
foreign
nothing grows
learn to embrace the storm of your life
sacrifice a few years of comfort
for decades of freedom
have patience
all things are difficult before they
become easy
the meaning of life is to give life
meaning
don't let yesterday take up too much of
today
never make a permanent decision based on
temporary feelings
if you get tired learn to rest
not to quit
the two most important days in your life
are the day you are born
and the day you find out why
stop waiting for the right time
isn't waiting for you
you do not find a happy life
you make it
as you know life is an echo
we get what we give
hardship often prepares an ordinary
person
for an extraordinary destiny
positive thinking will let you do
everything better then negative thinking
will
every day is a new beginning
treat it that way
stop thinking about what might have been
and start looking at what can be
whatever you are
be a good one
the only real mistake is the one from
which we learn nothing
life has many different chapters for us
one bad chapter doesn't mean it's the
end of the book
self-care mindset
I never lose
either I win or I learn
normality is a paved Road
it's comfortable to walk
but no flowers grow there
your comfort zone will destroy your
dreams
train your mind to be calm in every
situation
you only pass through this life once
you don't come back for an encore
your past is a place to learn and grow
not a place to live
don't rush the process
trust it
great things take time
Big Dreams require healthy habits
and healthy habits require
self-discipline
be proud
you survived the days you thought you
couldn't
you are at your strongest
when you are calm
if you stay positive in a negative
situation
you win
move in silence
only speak when it's time to say
checkmate
sometimes you win
sometimes you'll learn
stop calling it to dream
start calling it a plan
take a deep breath
it's just a bad day not a bad life
train your mind to see the good in
everything
fall seven times
stand up eight
if you believe it will work out
you'll see opportunities
if you believe it won't
you will see obstacles
remain focused
your time is coming
if you don't try
nothing will ever happen
judge no one
just improve yourself
train your mind to be stronger than your
feelings
don't give up on yourself
there's a reason why you started
be obsessed with becoming the best
version of yourself
when in your mind
and you will win in your reality
making mistakes is better than faking
Perfections
don't change your vibe to fit in someone
else's life
growth doesn't happen in your comfort
zone
a warrior is someone who gets up
even when he can't
there is no growth without pain
being alone is a power very few can
handle
except what is
let go of what was
have faith in what will be
if you control your thoughts you control
your life
do not let the behavior of others
destroy your inner peace
the calmer you are
the clearer you think
move with strategy
not emotion
a journey of a Thousand Miles begins
with a single step
don't allow your emotions to overpower
your intelligence
confidence is built by facing what you
fear
a Calm Mind makes a wiser decision
look forward with hope
not backwards with regret
the best things are yet to come
trust yourself
don't complain
rebuild yourself
is a rough road that leads to the
heights of greatness
the quality of your thinking determines
the quality of your life
nobody is coming to save you
get up
be your own hero
patience is power
discipline converts your dreams into
reality
turn the pain into power
the moment when you want to quit
it's the moment when you need to keep
pushing
control your thoughts or your thoughts
will control you
become a ghost
forget attention
just grow in private
expectations can mentally destroy you
push yourself to be your best
no one else is going to do it for you
let your past make you better
not bitter
focus on improving yourself
not proving yourself
your time is your most precious asset
don't waste it
if you can build muscle
you can build a mindset
don't over share
privacy is power
control your emotions
learn to react less
don't call it a problem
instead call it a challenge
believing in yourself is the first
secret of success
a negative mind will never give you a
positive life
don't count the days make the days count
two things Define you
your patience when you have nothing
and your attitude when you have
everything
if you can stay positive in a negative
situation
you win
your greatest asset in the world is your
mindset
don't quit
nothing lasts forever
not even pain
the way you speak to yourself matters
the most
there is no growth without discomfort
keep it private
until it's permanent
never tolerate disrespect
not even from yourself
better days are coming
be patient
no regrets in life
just Lessons Learned
you don't need more time
you need less distractions
fix your thoughts
fix your life
everyone leaves
learn how to survive alone
value your peace of mind
you can't reach what's in front of you
you let go of what's behind you
don't blame the distractions
improve your focus
before you act decide
before you decide
think
before you think
Focus
one day you will thank yourself for not
giving up
your failure does not define you
your persistence does
give a man a fish and you feed him for a
day
teach a man to fish
feed him for a lifetime
your comfort zone is killing your
potential
take the risk
or lose the chance
be obsessed with improving yourself
to be the best you must be able to
handle the worst
words without action mean nothing
your only limit
is you
judge no one
just improve yourself
failure is the greatest teacher
except what you can't change
change what you can't accept
when you learn to survive without anyone
you can survive anything
a goal without a plan
is just a wish
don't regret the past
just learn from it
give love to all
hatred to none
Change the World by being yourself
die with memories
not dreams
aspire to inspire before you expire
everything you can imagine
is real
Simplicity is the ultimate
sophistication
whatever you do
it well
tough times never last but tough people
do
problems are not stop signs they are
guidelines
have enough courage to start and enough
heart to finish
determine your priorities and focus on
them
he's so good they can't ignore you
dream as if you'll live forever
live as if you'll die today
yesterday you said tomorrow
just do it
foreign
s are a blessing
try to be a rainbow in someone's cloud
there is no substitute for hard work
what consumes your mind
controls your life
wanting to be someone else
is a waste of Who You Are
the time is always right to do what is
right
let the beauty of what you love be what
you do
[Music]
may your choices reflect your hopes
not your fears
life becomes easier when you learn to
accept the apology you'd never got
happiness depends upon ourselves
if the world was blind
how many people would you impress
you only live once
but if you do it right
once is enough
if you want to live a happy life
tie it to a goal
not to people or things
not how long but how well you have lived
is the main thing
if life were predictable
it would cease to be life and be without
flavor
the big lesson in life is never be
scared of anyone or anything
life is not a problem to be solved
but a reality to be experienced
everything negative
pressure
challenges
is all an opportunity for you to rise
life is like riding a bicycle
to keep your balance you must keep
moving
the healthiest response to life
is joy
come and carry on
the greatest pleasure of life
is love
life is about making an impact not
making an income
too many of us are not living our dreams
because we are living our fears
be happy for this moment
this moment is your life
is short
and it is here to be lived
it is our choices that show what we
truly are
far more than our abilities
the best way to predict your future
to create it
there are no mistakes
only opportunities
life is like a coin
you can spend it any way you wish
but you only spend it once
as you grow older you will discover that
you have two hands
one for helping yourself
the other
for helping others
sometimes you can't see yourself clearly
until you see yourself Through The Eyes
of others
do not dwell in the past do not dream of
the future
concentrate the mind on the present
moment
in the end some of your greatest pains
become your greatest strengths
nothing is more honorable
than a grateful heart
find people
who will make you better
today you have 100 of your life left
nobody who ever gave his best regretted
it
make each day your masterpiece
if things go wrong don't go with them
be yourself
everyone else is already taken
positive anything is better than
negative nothing
to improve is to change
to be perfect is to change often
every accomplishment starts with the
decision to try
not all those who wander are lost
try not to become a man of success
rather become a man of value
begin be bold
and venture to be wise
foreign